I'm always dealing with constipation, trying to get a number of magnesium capsules and
allocapsules correct.
I've had a bit of success with taking straight coconut oil actually, but I have noticed
I seem to have lost the natural urge to have a moment.
Can my daily animals be responsible for the lack of peristolsis?
Yes, that's what it's called, making my balls lazy.
So yes, if you're doing daily coffee animals for a long time, it can affect your urge to
go and you can feel like you can become dependent upon the coffee animal.
So if your cancers in remission, you don't need to continue to do coffee animals.
Typically, your balls get back in order within about a week.
If you've always had to deal with constipation, you do want to kind of look at other possible
issues going on, and you've got two, do you have, you know, again, I don't have your full
history in front of me.
Did you ever have a surgery that could have caused adhesions?
Do you have, are you going to a car parter that does adhesiology?
They may want to check your illiosecal valve.
It's the valve between your large and small intestine that could be blocked.
I think I talk a little bit about the illiosecal valve in the video on how to deal with a heightal
herdea.
That's on our blogs.
If you go to our blog and you search heightal herdea, I give a video demonstration on how
to pull down the heightal herdea.
And I think in that video, I made it number of years ago, but I think I talk about a height
illiosecal valve issue in there as well.
So check that, that might be part of your issue, that would be a simple fix.
And then just the health of the gut as far as, you know, damage, gut wall, and such can be issues with constipation.
And then a big thing with constipation is, and big thing with the health of the gut are people
are not testing for food sensitivities and dealing with that.
And they're like, part of it is that, and you might be in this category that the test is expensive.
It's 500 some bucks, so you don't want to do it.
Other people are in the category that, you know, I can eat anything.
My stomach's like a rock, and I don't have any sensitivities, and I don't feel bad after
I eat things.
And they're failing to understand that you're not looking for pain or discomfort after eating
as your sign of inflammation of the gut.
So remember, the only pain fibers you have in the intestinal tract are distention fibers.
I could literally go in there and cut up your intestinal tract, you won't feel a thing.
Of course you plead to death, that wouldn't be a good experiment.
But you don't have pain fibers except fibers that cause, that are, that are distention fibers.
And you have gas billed up and all my tummy really hurts.
So you don't get, you know, gas billed up and you're tummy really hurting, always when you
have an inflammatory reaction in the gut.
So, um, testing for things, and I've had people run the test and have nothing come up.
Well, that's just great.
But more commonly, I'm person run the test and they swear, I know nothing's going to come
up and a whole bunch of things come up.
Perseveral things come up and they go, oh my goodness, I guess I eat that a lot.
And then you can look up and see what's across reacted to that thing.
And you go, wow, I need to stay off of that.
Um, I've had people be on a gluten-free dairy-free diet.
I think they're doing everything right.
Do a CyRex 10 and they come up with, you know, some food product that is in gluten-free foods,
you know, like tapioca starch and they're, you know, show up in the red for tapioca starch.
And they may be able to search every time they eat gluten-free bread.
And that's just as bad as eating gluten for that person.
So, but they never had any symptoms.
But so, testing for that can be why is they to do it.